hey this is pressure Hawker the leg of a
right triangle is equal to one-fifth the
sum of the other sides the triangle has
a perimeter of one what is the triangles
area can you figure it out
give this prom a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution well solve this problem by
setting up a right triangle that has
legs of a and B and a hypotenuse C we
are told the leg of the right triangle
is equal to one-fifth the sum of the
other size so write out that a is equal
to B plus C divided by five this
equation can equivalently be written as
five times a is equal to B plus C we
also know the triangle has a perimeter
of one this means a plus B plus C is
equal to one will now use the
information that B plus C is equal to
five a and we can then solve that a is
equal to 1/6 we need to solve for one
more side of the triangle so we'll use
this information back in our equation
about a B and C well solve for C in this
equation that will get c is equal to 5/6
minus b to solve for b we'll need to
know one more thing
we'll use the Pythagorean theorem we
have eight groups of b squared is equal
to C squared we know the value for a and
we know an expression for C in terms of
B so we can simplify this equation and
simplify further to solve that b is
equal to 2/5 we now solve with the two
legs of this right triangle and we can
therefore calculate the area as the
product of the legs / - this gets to the
answer of 1 divided by 30 so that's one
way to solve the problem but there is a
shortcut if you think creatively
so you're given the property that's the
leg of the right triangle is equal to
one-fifth of some of the other side a
problem like this was used in
competition math do you know any right
triangles with this property if you go
through some of the familiar triangles
you might think about the five twelve
thirteen right triangle in which five is
equal to one-fifth the sum of twelve and
thirteen we can calculate the perimeter
of this triangle at 30 and its area is
30 now we're interested in a triangle
with the perimeter one so we can just
guess that maybe this is similar to a
triangle with the perimeter of one we
don't have to prove it it's competition
math we're interested in just the answer
in the later part of this video I'm
going to show you these two triangles
are in fact similar but for now let's
just assume they're similar so if that
were the case we could then calculate
the area because the sides would be
scaled by 1 over xxx and that means the
area scaled by 1 over 30 squared so we
can use the areas of 5 12 13 triangle
scale up by 1 over 30 squares and we
again get to the answer of 1 over 30 you
might see how this principle could help
us assume you're thinking of another
problem where the leg is equal to 1/2 to
some of the other side do you know any
special triangles losses property well
think about the 3 4 5 right triangle you
know that's the leg of 4 is equal to 3
plus 5 divided by 2 so in this triangle
its perimeter is equal to 12 and it's
area is equal to 6 so just guess that is
similar to the triangle with perimeter 1
in that case we want the side to scale
by 1 over 12 and the area to be
proportional by 1 over 12 squared so we
take the area of the 3 4 5 right
triangle scale it by 1 over 12 squared
and we get to the answer of 1 over 24 so
this is all sign for competition math
and getting to the answer but now let's
go through the algebra and make sure
that the triangles are in fact similar
and we can try and solve this problem
more generally 2 so imagine we have the
leg of a right triangle is equal to 1
over n the sum of the other side and
this will be for an appropriate
a value that not all values of n will
work here so we'll just assume that the
value then does work we know that the
triangle has a perimeter or sorry we'll
go ahead and set up this equation that
one side is equal to 1 over n the sum of
the other side we can rewrite this as n
times a is equal to B plus C we have
this two triangle as a primitive one so
we have the sum of the sides is equal to
one we can then substitute in the value
of B plus C is equal to n times a and we
can actually solve that a is equal to 1
divided by the quantity n plus 1 so now
we're going to need to solve for the
side B so we'll substitute in this value
for a in our equation relating a B and C
we get that C is equal to n divided by
the quantity n plus 1 minus B will now
go through the Pythagorean theorem we
know the value for a we know C in terms
of B and I'll skip some of the algebra
and we'll just get to the answer that B
is equal to n minus 1 the quantity
divided by 2 lengths so we now have the
two legs a and B and we can calculate
the area as the project of the legs / -
so we get to a general expression that
the area will be the quantity n minus 1
divided by the quantity 4 n squared + or
ñ you can now substitute in this for any
value of n when you have a triangle with
the perimeter of 1 now what would happen
if the triangle had a different
perimeter are the sides actually going
to be similar are the triangles can be
similar will the side scale and we'll
the area scale appropriately well let's
find out
so let's assume we have a triangle with
a perimeter of K now so we'll go through
the same step we're going to find out
exactly the same thing the main
difference here is we have a perimeter
of K and you can already see that the
side a is equal to K divided by n plus 1
so the side a has already failed from
our previous problem as we go through
the remaining step we're going to find
out that this side B is also going to
scale compared to the triangle with the
perimeter 1 so the area's equals of
product a is like divided by 2
and since the sides are scales the area
will also scale appropriately so the
legs a and B are scaled by K the
triangle is similar to the one with
primitive one and the air results was
scaled by K squared
so we've now proven this problem quite
generally four triangles of one over N
equal to one over N to some of the other
sides and for any arbitrary perimeter k
did you figure this out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch repulsion media app pressure
Walker and if you like this video please
check out my book there are links in the
video description